legendary air force pilot chuck yeager
died last night the retired one star
general was the first person to break
the sound barrier becoming an almost
mythical american hero yeager was 97
years old
our national correspondent jerica duncan
looks at the life and career of a
country boy who became the model
for the right stuff
[Music]
it was october 14 1947
and chuck yeager was already an
accomplished world war
ii pilot who shot down more than a dozen
german adversaries
across 64 missions but on that day
the 24 year old captain in the army air
corps
set his course for the history books and
he does it
the first human to crack the sound
barrier
[Music]
65 years later to the minute he rode
along to re-create the historic flight
across a decades-long career all the
aircraft he flew were named glamorous
glennis
for his first wife who died in 1990.
until that time
we'd never been able to get above the
street of sound pushing
through mach 1 open up space to us
breaking the sound barrier wasn't
yeager's only brush with speed
he broke mach 2 twice the speed of sound
in 1953
and his sonic booms would set the
standard for pushing the limits of
flight
jaeger later played a key role in
developing u.s space exploration
training nearly half of the astronauts
who served in the gemini
mercury and apollo programs
those milestones would later be
memorialized in a book and film
the right stuff i'm still going upstairs
like a bat out of hell
we didn't even know that we would ever
break
mach 1. it's not a matter of thinking
that it's possible
it's duty it's just like flying combat
it didn't make any difference to me
whether i thought the airplane would go
fast and sound
i was a signed as a as a test pilot on
it
and it was my duty to fly
so 24 i think when you think of grit
that's what you think
i mean think about the story you told
tony well i was gonna say the first
flight
of anything was 1903 yeah and then just
40 years later we're going mach
1 and he's the one doing he was asked on
twitter how did how did breaking the
sound barrier feel and
he wrote considering everyone was sure
anyone who did would blow
all apart to pieces surviving was good
so the right stuff is one of my favorite
books there's a lot of stories you could
tell actually i think the better one is
any time you hear a pilot even to this
day talk on
on the intercom about like well i'm
going to go up around here and duck
around here
they are mimicking the style of chuck
yeager
his voice in the cockpit is the voice
that all pilots use that's what that's
what tom wolf reported
he was an aviation legend you know from
the moment that he broke the sound
barrier but
right stuff made him a hero he does have
the right stuff